540 kilometer soll der jet für 150
passagiere zurücklegen und das rein
elektrisch so die pläne eines
kalifornischen start up unternehmens
bereits 2021 könnte der erste prototyp
abheben und norwegen plant sogar schon
vollelektrische kurzstreckenflüge
elektrisches fliegen also jetzt schon
möglich jetzt zwei klicks und science
fiction herzlich willkommen und am ende
des videos habe ich übrigens ein
geschenk für euch von technology review
in zusammenarbeit mit dieser quoten
zeitschrift ist nämlich dieses video
hier entstanden
ja der trend in der luftfahrt der ist
fatal und elektrisch betriebenen
flugzeuge könnten ihn bremsen auch wenn
die triebwerke immer effizienter werden
und dass treibstoff einsparen kann diese
positive entwicklung das anhaltende
wachstum des transportaufkommens nicht
wieder gut machen und so ist man
mittlerweile davon weggekommen einzig
und allein auf die entwicklung neuer
triebwerke zu setzen um dieses problem
anzugehen als möglicher neuer ansatz
gelten jetzt hybridantriebe bei
flugzeugen die jets für 150 passagiere
des kalifornischen startups light
electric das rund 540 kilometer weit
kommen soll will easyjet schon 2027 in
seine flotte aufnehmen der zeitplan
eines norwegischen flughafenbetreibers
der sieht das für 2040 vor
und da sollen die kleinen flieger voll
elektrisch sein kleinere anbieter wollen
das schon vorher schaffen wenn auch
zunächst einmal mit kleineren modellen
ein us start up beispielsweise will
schon in vier jahren seinen 16 meter
lang wie bridget für zwölf passagiere in
die luft bringen 1130 kilometer weit
soll dieser jet kommen und das mit einem
tempo von bis zu 550 kilometern pro
stunde
die betriebskosten könnten sich achtung
um 80 prozent senken und zwar durch
spriteinsparungen und geringere
wartungskosten der er einfach gebauten
elektroantriebe im vergleich zu
herkömmlichen flugzeugen sei außerdem
mit 75 prozent weniger lärm zu rechnen
doch nicht alle fachleute auf diesem
gebiet sehen die hybriden schon so weit
vorne zumindest nicht in der nahen
zukunft denn für sie sei die
batterietechnologie noch gar nicht so
weit der notwendige durchbruch dafür
ließe noch auf sich warten und frank
anton der chef der siemens ir kraft
sparte doch für komplett ausgeschlossen
hält er die vision nicht jedenfalls
für alle bereiche außer finnischen wie
den kurzstrecken transport in megacities
wird es in den nächsten drei jahrzehnten
keinen vollelektrischen antrieb geben
damit sind mini drohnen gemeint die
kurze strecken vollelektrisch fliegen
was technologisch schon komplett gelöst
ist siemens dagegen arbeitet an dem
sogenannten seriellen hybridantrieb
das projekt laufe auch schon und man
erwarte eine echte umwälzung der
luftfahrt bis 2020 soll dem plan zufolge
ein hybrid elektrische antriebsstrang in
170 s regional flugzeug eingebaut werden
und abheben
siemens zufolge könnte dadurch der lärm
effektiv gemindert werden und treibstoff
im zweistelligen prozentbereich
eingespart werden das prinzip sieht so
aus ein generator im rumpf produziert
strom
er selbst wird durch eine gasturbine
angetrieben die auf kerosin läuft der so
produzierte strom treibt elektromotoren
mit den rotoren an so dass die nötige
leistung auf mehrere kleinere
elektromotoren verteilt wird zu finden
dann an heck oder am flügel das ganz
neue formen in sachen aerodynamik und
flugzeug design möglich macht die
jeweilige batterie würde je nach
einsatzgebiet des hybrid flugzeugs
ausgewählt und die turbine je nachdem
wie viele elektrische energie für den
flug gebraucht wird beim staat würde der
strom aus den akkus für einen extra
schub sorgen
die batterien könnten durch die turbine
dann während der flugzeit wieder
aufgeladen werden noch effektiver wäre
es wenn der luftstrom im sinkflug die
propeller bewegen würde und somit auch
die elektromotoren
diese fungieren dann als generatoren die
die batterien wieder auffüllen das kennt
man von elektroautos wo beim bremsen
strom rekuperiert wird doch dieses
konzept hat nicht nur vorteile sondern
auch einen gravierenden nachteil die
leistung wird in form von elektromotoren
batterien und gasturbinen quasi dreimal
verbaut und das bringt erhebliche
gewichts nachteile mit sich die große
frage dazu lautet also können die
vorteile die die verteilten
elektroantriebe mit sich bringen diese
gewichts nachteile wieder ausgleichen
noch kann die forschung dazu keine
antwort geben
ich sag mal vielen dank an technology
review in zusammenarbeit mit der
redaktion dieser ziemlich coolen
zeitschrift jemand ziemlich weit vorne
mit dabei ist dieses video entstanden
und exklusiv für pixum zuschauer habe
ich jetzt ein geschenk
ihr bekommt
mich eine ausgabe gratis wenn ihr auf
diesen link klickt das soll sich
wirklich und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken so funktioniert
fliegen oder nicht da erfahrt ihr warum
fliegen nicht so geht wie es im
unterricht meistens erklärt wird bis
dann bleibt dran